welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness originally led off
with a shocking opening sequence that
would have given us maramardo but like
every wishlist cameo who got face time
with the scarlet witch was promptly met
with a what face as wanda learned a
lesson from the guy who took everything
from her and went for the head again and
again and again apparently in this movie
yes friends mordo beheaded in a removed
opening scene of this movie that would
have better explained mordo's too many
sorcerers ending to the 2016 film
strange's awkward recap in 838 and some
mysterious promo imagery that was left
out of theatrical cut and this video is
sponsored by story blocks more on them
later so i'm going to explain what this
deleted alternate opening was and
actually show you what it would have
looked like since they teased more of it
than we realized in the marketing now
this comes to us by the way of our
friend paul from the heavy spoilers
channel my uk variant whom i
occasionally dream walk into or let him
dream walk into me don't ask it's it's
too sexy for youtube but the man has an
inside source confirming that multiverse
of madness did indeed include at some
point in the post-production process a
sequence with the 616 mordo facing 616
wanda now you remember the theatrical
cut of this film opens with the
fantastical imagery of the gap junction
as defenders strange in america chavez
flee a ribbon monster one that we later
learn is being controlled by wanda the
action is heart-pounding so no
complaints but you may have felt it
might be a little out of character for
sam raimi and michael waldron to open
this film with neither of the primary
lead characters with a cgi spectacle
that doesn't quite match the themes and
the tone for the rest of the film like
it's a kind of fun sequence that works
great in a first act to set the stakes
and yank you into the story but as a
prologue to a horror film with massacres
and morals being delivered by corpses
this sequence felt a tad candy land in
fact for the whole opening 15 minutes of
this movie we just assumed this gap
junction sequence might have just been a
dream of 616 strange add this to the
fact that the movie weirdly glosses over
mordo's arc from the 2016 film when he
broke away from strange and wong and was
last seen slaughtering and hobbying
wizards too many saucers strange
references this when he and america meet
the 838 version of mordo strange says
he's actually the first guy who let me
into comartage and then he snapped and
dedicated his life to try to kill me
they stare each other down then surprise
838 mordo greets him with a warm hug
this scene feels like a punch line to a
setup we never quite received
structurally there probably should have
been some story beat that tracked
mordo's anti-sorcerer crusade to cast
him as an anti-magical avenger villain
so that his hug was strange in 838 would
pay off as a satisfying reversal but
according to this new report such a
story beat was indeed part of this movie
originally was removed reportedly
multiverse of madness originally opened
with mordo tracking down wanda to her
residence in that corrupted orchard to
punish her for what she did in westview
and then almost immediately wanda
beheads mordo imprinting her to us as a
cruel villain in this whole story to be
as much about wanda's actions as it is
about strange's actions and then that
would have led to the minion that the
scarlet witch puppets the ribbon monster
chasing down wanda's target america
chavez now this deleted opening scene
was actually hinted at in an official
poster for the movie released by screen
x in the bottom right the ruins of a
house mordo walking up to it with a
sword strapped to his back and wanda
peering out at him from the window this
poster was also the one that gives our
first clear look at the book of ashanti
so these artists seemed a bit more
liberal with their depictions of the
opening act of the film now this is the
same broken house that we saw in the
background of wanda's orchard a set
piece left as a mysterious loose end
pointing at what exactly wana was doing
in this location i've also been having a
bit of fun with how the very first
teaser for this film included that shot
of a random crow squawking at us a shot
that was never in the film but when you
look closely at this shot the red
lighting around the bird this was
probably some tone setting spookiness
from this removed opening sequence with
mordo now this opening sequence likely
would have confirmed where exactly this
orchard is now one could assume this
ruined house is the same cabin wanda was
in the one of vision post credits scene
a scene that we now know marvel
re-edited a few months after the initial
upload changing the trees that surround
the cabin but this orchard neither the
flowery illusion nor its twisted
corrupted true state seems to border
that mountain lake that the wanavision
cabin was situated beside so this might
be a new location that wanda resettled
in after that cabin maybe one of a
series of locations that wanda hopped
around to fleeing mordo like her days on
the run with vision until through the
darkhold she became powerful and corrupt
enough to stand her ground and fight
back now one of the tools we use here at
new rockstar is to make our videos
better is storyblocks a storyblocks
membership is essential for any creator
thanks to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video they have a huge
demand-driven royalty-free library full
of 4k and hd footage after effects and
premiere pro templates music images and
sound effects to bring your stories to
life we've got the unlimited all access
plan which gives you unlimited downloads
for the over 1 million assets in their
library choose from one of their
flexible subscriptions at scale to give
you all the content and tools you need
to focus on creating not worrying about
budget and if you're a member of a large
creative team marketing agency or media
organization their enterprise license
has your back with comprehensive
coverage for your entire company that
enables you to distribute wherever
whenever so go to storyblocks.com new
rockstars now or click the link in the
description to check out their unlimited
all-access plan today now sam raimi
included this interesting close-up of a
crate that wanda toss the branches into
labeled yolkers which i thought might be
a nod to window volker a minor character
from a thunderbolt zemo storyline he's
an academic who works with reed richards
to uncover that zemo had gone back in
time maybe this crate is a reference to
him or someone else but either way it
just seems specific enough that it could
have pointed to who really owns this
estate the person that wanda took it
over from and the way that mordo was
able to find her in this deleted opening
scene now by removing this opening scene
it definitely changes how we look at the
opening act and at the entire film it
makes multiverse of madness more of a
doctor strange movie than a wanda movie
and it delays the reveal of wanda's dark
turn to the moment she uses america's
name despite strange never saying it
making out a really cool twist but
really and i think this might be the
reason it was cut is that it just avoids
a super violent shocking intro which
might have been done as a concession to
sensors both the mpaa and abroad as
let's be honest this movie is already
toeing the line of an r-rating with one
illuminati massacre i mean this is going
to sound dumb but it is how it works
sensors are more likely to object to
mature content in the opening minutes of
a film than stuff later on in the movie
maybe because easily triggered audiences
are more likely to object to stuff when
they're still forming of an opinion of a
movie as they're working through their
popcorn than they are an hour into a
movie after they've already been won
over like that f-bomb and x-men first
class they didn't put in the opening
minutes of the film they buried it an
hour in don't [ __ ] yourself and i think
the downside of these concerns over
censorship is that it may have deprived
us all of a chance to see wanda's
downfall as a result of that cursed
darkhold's corruption of her soul
context that i think might have helped
some who saw this film digest wanda's
transition from dealing with her grief
and wandavision to these violent
outbursts in this movie this opening
scene with mordo could have been a
stepping stone to that as she defends
herself from mordo's slaughter and says
well if he can kill people maybe i can
too i mean the good news for 616 mordo
is he now still gets to be alive in the
616 universe good for you chubby tail
now we don't know how much this deleted
opening scene would have gone into it
but i can tell you the mere sight of a
witch alone in this broken house with
nothing but her solitude and an evil
book to keep her company just one scene
of that would have given me quite a bit
of emotional context for why wanda does
what she does but you know i also can't
argue with the choice in a two-hour
superhero movie to reveal a character's
true moral alignment with this haunting
visual twist followed by some great
cold-hearted bitterness delivered so
perfectly by elizabeth olsen this whole
orchard scene as it was in theatrical
cut was definitely one of my favorite
scenes of the film so i can't fault it
but i want to hear your thoughts comment
down below do you think this scene
should have been kept in the film or is
it better off without it follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
your rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign